now 6 44 Monday morning a local
principal said he's had enough he says
drivers are speeding near his school
creating a dangerous situation for
students well it actually comes as
lawmakers are proposing placing cameras
in school zones Joshua peguero joining
us live from Mountain View Christian
School along 13th and Fremont Joshua
good morning
good morning Heather and John the
principal of Mountain View says drivers
just ignore the school zone speeding
sign behind me what you see is 15 miles
per hour and he says he's concerned for
the safety of those dropping off
students
certainly cars that are going even
beyond the regular speed limit of 35
miles an hour there's cars that are that
are Trucking through there at you know
40 50 miles an hour principal Raymond
above says they've hired security to
monitor a 13th Street in the mornings
and afternoons in the three years since
the school moved to this building
speeding has been a problem and he wants
drivers to follow the law even the
people that are speeding get aggravated
our cars that are trying to turn in and
that's a concern of an accident there is
an effort in the Nevada legislature to
clamp down on these drivers
assemblywoman Danielle Monroe Moreno has
proposed ab-93 this bill would give
municipalities and agencies the option
to place a camera in school zones only
when school is in session if you're
caught speeding you'd face a civil
penalty I slow down when I get to the
school zone but not everyone around me
and you're not supposed to pass anyone
in a school zone but I often get passed
up in a school zone
why
it's usually a 30-minute stress during
the afternoon that's really bad for
Speeders especially along 13th Street
and is encouraging people heading out
this morning to just slow down reporting
live along 13 through Indiana Fremont
Joshua peguero eight news now